hey y'all doing another movie review
today
so the film that we are talking about
this is one that has been on my to watch
list like forever i remember this movie
gosh it was um i kind of feel like it
got wide release it's technically 2016
but it got wide released in 2017 so i
kind of feel like it turned up on a lot
of people's best horror movies of that
year list and i was like oh man that
sounds really good and so i put it on my
list and then i just never really got
around to it but then uh shutter added
it not too long ago so finally i was
like finally i'm gonna get around to
watching this movie that i've heard so
much about
now this is a movie called
hounds of love now i will say that this
movie is very much in the vein
it's loosely based on a true
crime and i'll get into that a little
bit like what the differences of it were
and it's pretty difficult to watch it
doesn't really shy away from the events
of it but i it is rather
i don't even know if tasteful is the
right word but it does like actually a
lot of the stuff that happens in it is
by implication
rather than showing it graphically um so
it doesn't really have
it doesn't really have the same kind of
like sleazy like exploitative kind of
thing about it because it does kind of
pull its punches but in some ways i
think that kind of makes it like
creepier because a lot of the stuff is
just kind of left to your imagination
like you know what's happening but
they're not going to like splash it
right in your face um but you imagining
it kind of makes it worse
so there's that so this is movie is not
uh the kind of movie that you go into
for a good time it's not any fun to
watch it's uh you know it's not really a
piece of art that's meant to be enjoyed
necessarily but that said uh it's
actually like a really brilliant
film i mean i like i said enjoy it isn't
the word
but i got really really invested in this
and i was just really i mean it's a very
intense
brutal uh watch so if you're not down
with stuff like
i don't know like snow town um or
henry portrait of serial killer or the
girl next door stuff like that this is
along those lines so if you don't want
to watch something like that and i'm not
blaming you if you don't because it's
unpleasant
uh then you know maybe you want to give
it a pass but as i said it's actually
like quite a brilliant film it's
brilliantly shot
it's just the acting is incredible it
kind of like bums me out and i was like
watching another review of this earlier
that said you know it's kind of a shame
that horror movies don't really get i
mean it's gotten a little bit better
like recently but they don't really get
the same
i guess recognition uh when there's
really good acting or really good you
know screenplay or something like that
they tend to really get overlooked in
favor of other things like dramas and
whatnot and that's really a shame
because uh the three principal actors in
this are quite amazing and it's just
like a really powerful like brave
performance that all of them put forth
so as i said hounds of love came out in
2016 it's an australian film
and it is the directorial debut believe
it or not uh of a guy named ben young i
don't know if he's done anything
subsequently um i probably should have
checked but well he didn't have like a
wikipedia page of his own so i'm
assuming and i forgot to check imtv but
this was kind of like his debut and as i
said it turned up on a lot of critics
best of lists
now this movie is very loosely based
well kind of loosely based
on
uh the serial killer couple
david and catherine bernie now we might
have talked about them because i kind of
feel like for a while
um on the regular show we were doing
like for valentine's day we would do
like killer couples and would usually do
like three or four of them on one show
and i kind of feel like these
[ __ ] were you know people that
we talked about because that sounds very
familiar uh but yeah they were
a serial killer couple that operated in
perth western australia in 1986
would basically abduct
rape torture and then murder uh teenage
girls or you know young women in their
20s
they actually had i believe five victims
now the last one did get away
now their final victim the one that
escaped and the one that helped them get
brought to justice
uh her name is kate moore i believe more
or more i'm not sure how you pronounce
that last name she actually wrote a book
about her experiences called dead girl
walking she was not a big fan of
this movie being made
because she felt as though well this is
just giving
you know these serial killers attention
that they don't deserve i can see that
and that is a completely valid i mean
because she went through this [ __ ] i
mean so obviously she can uh have that
opinion on it
but
i don't know i kind of feel like this
movie it's
it's similar to what really happened but
it's different enough uh particularly
the ending and things like that
that you could just kind of treat this
as more an exploration of
this type of thing happening and this
interestingly because i think i've
brought up like whenever we do true
crime shows about
serial killer couples it's not common uh
but it does happen and i'm always kind
of like fascinated by the whole dynamic
there
and uh the filmmakers of this movie said
that they did actually yes david and
catherine burning was kind of like the
main thing that they based it on but
they also did
sort of look into the psychology the
dynamic between serial killer couples
like what happens in between them so
they wanted to kind of put that and
honestly the psychology the examination
of the psychology of the serial killer
couple in this is probably one of the
greatest strengths in the movie and that
was one of the things that was the most
different from the actual case so
what is this movie about as i said now
like i said this is kind of it's very
very brutal it's not
you know it's not a fun time uh and like
i said it reminded me very much of
snowtown which was also a great movie
although i think i liked this one a
little bit better although i haven't
seen snowtown in a long time what we
have there is a couple they're named
john and evelyn
or evie as she's called for short
and there are these creeps now this
movie even though the real [ __ ] happened
in perth western australia in 1986
this is set in purse western australia
but like later on it's set like in
december of 1987 so it's set right
around uh christmas time uh although
like i said southern hemisphere it's
australia so it's like the middle of
summer but it's also christmas time
which lends it a little bit more horror
i guess because it's like oh this
festive time of year and like all this
[ __ ] horrible [ __ ] is happening now
the very beginning you have this couple
and
they seem to be
looking for somebody you know for their
next victim i guess and like there's
this really good like opening tracking
shot which is an ultra ultra slow motion
of like all these kind of high school
girls teenage girls like playing netball
and the way that
you know when the um credits are going
like just these kind of slow motion kind
of things like on their arms and their
knees and things like that so it almost
has this like voyeuristic because you're
seeing it framed from the perspective of
this
couple of sleaze bags that are
you know watching they're like which one
are we gonna pick you know and just like
looking at them so it's just a very
voyeuristic like uncomfortable this is a
movie
not just because it's set in the 80s and
everything is like kind of dirty and
covered with wood paneling and kind of
gross but also because of the subject
matter this is definitely a movie that
you will definitely feel like really
really nasty afterward like oh my god i
need to like scrub like i need a bleach
shower you know a silkwood shower it's
one of those kind of movies um so like i
said you kind of have to be in the right
headspace to like want to watch that
type of thing and it's probably not a
movie that you want to watch more than
once but
it is definitely i i don't know i did
find it a very compelling experience
like i said it's not enjoyable because
it's very unpleasant but i don't know
because i i do kind of feel like i was
watching um there's this one channel
called we watched a movie and it's just
these two they're really funny they're
kind of like it's that's not normally
the type of movie reviews i would like
because usually they're kind of like
shouting but they go off on like a lot
of uh tangents like we do so i guess i
can't really criticize but uh they were
watching this movie and they both
actually quite liked it although they
said yeah we needed a shower afterwards
um but the one guy and i kind of feel
like this was underlying and like some
people that didn't like this movie were
kind of like well why was this movie
made i mean it's not and like i said
it's not i didn't find it to be
exploitative in the sense that it's just
exploiting a true crime
for
you know titillation purposes it's not
titillating in the least
and honestly i've made this argument
before that
making a movie like this that's you know
sort of ostensibly loosely based on a
real thing that happened uh and making
it unpleasant
i kind of feel like people have a
problem with that but i think that the
underlying assumption there is that
movies or art in general uh should only
be made to bring people happiness or
enjoyment and i don't think that's the
case i mean i think art of any kind uh
can be used to explore a wide range of
uh emotions and you know and different
things so
i don't think that it's necessarily like
i said this isn't something you want to
watch like to have a good time but i
don't think there's anything wrong with
you if you want to watch it either and
to be honest if you're going to show a
movie like this which is loosely based
on something that did actually really
happen
i think that you're kind of not making
it titillating but making it realistic
which this absolutely is because this
[ __ ] really does happen and maybe you
know seeing it as it really happens will
you know kind of wake up something which
it's just like and you know uh it kind
of leads to a discussion we could have
about you know what can we do about
people like this how can we prevent this
things like that so i think there
actually is some value in making movies
like this but i can see how some people
might not
want to watch it because like i said
it's very unpleasant
so john and evie are this couple they
live in western australia and at the
beginning they're kind of like uh you
know kind of looking for this girl to
kidnap now interestingly the one that
they take at the very beginning is
actually not the victim that we're
following throughout the whole movie
they're just basically setting up
this is a pattern for them this is
something that they do every so often
um you know they just kind of show it
from far away
as this girl is walking home alone and
it's daytime it's not night or anything
it's just like afternoon she's walking
home through this sort of you know lower
to middle class like suburban
neighborhood in the 1980s
and she's just walking home and she you
know gets into the car with them because
they seem very friendly like i said it's
a couple uh you see later on that they
have a baby seat like in the back so you
wouldn't necessarily think oh big red
flag or anything like that it's not like
a creepy dude by himself it looks like a
family so she doesn't feel like there's
anything wrong
so she gets in the car and then later on
they show
uh the man like john like driving out
and basically like burying her body like
way out in the in the bush or whatever
so at that point we're introduced to uh
our other main character who is a
teenage girl named vicki
now she's going through uh some [ __ ]
she has a boyfriend who you know seems
like a nice dude and everything like
that and they do like a little bit of a
setup where you know they have this
thing where they kind of uh communicate
with one another like uh in letters
where you know she'll write out they'll
write out like uh whatever secret
message they want and it's just like the
first letter of each word you know what
i'm saying so it's just kind of like
this code they do so they establish that
so you know that that's going to like
play into some [ __ ] later on
now her parents are separating uh it
seems like her dad is quite well off i
believe he is a
surgeon of some kind which like i said
she's
vicki is not based on one of the real
victims she's kind of a composite of two
or three of them because one of the
actual victims i believe the one that
survived um i think her dad was uh was a
surgeon of some kind
too but like i said she's vicki is like
a composite of several of the victims so
she's not really one of the people
so her dad is a surgeon uh her mom
basically uh just not really for any
reasons that are stated forthrightly but
she's just kind of like look i want my
own life and i just want you to respect
that so she has moved away and it so
happens that she's moved to the suburban
neighborhood where the serial killer
lives like a few streets over like it's
a few blocks away or whatever obviously
she doesn't know that so um vicki is
really really unhappy about this uh
blames her mother uh she you know she
hates her mother you left us and it's
this whole thing what's like i said very
understandable because the girl's a
teenager
so uh so it happens i guess since
they're going through the separation she
wants to stay with her dad but her dad
is kind of like well you know you you
need to go stay with your mom
a couple nights a week or whatever so i
don't know if it was like some kind of
settlement they worked out because i
don't think they're divorced yet i think
they're just separated
so she begrudgingly uh goes to stay with
her mom
now her mom is just kind of like hey you
know we only see each other two nights a
week and we should hang out and she's
like well yeah that's your fault because
you left so [ __ ] you i'm going to a
party
and uh the mom is like you were
absolutely not going to a party because
your grades suck and you haven't done
your homework and blah blah she's trying
to like lay down the law it seems like
there's some implication that like the
dad is a lot more permissive uh so it's
just kind of like she's used to kind of
being able to do what she wants
and you know she started she's not a bad
kid she's actually like a good kid but
she has like started to kind of like
blow off school or whatever
uh but her mom's trying to lay down the
law she's like you're absolutely not
going to a party you're going to stay
here uh you know we're going to watch a
movie you're going to do your homework
and like i said because your grades are
bad
so obviously she gets pissed off about
this and sneaks out
so she sneaks out of the bedroom window
at which point she is approached by john
and evie who it appears i don't think
they target anyone specifically they
seem like they're mostly just kind of
like
driving around rather like sharks like
just looking for opportunities like
whoever it is that's alone whoever it is
they can lure into their car because
they don't
they have a thing where and like i said
this i kind of feel like this happens a
lot like in real life like
with these serial killer couples i'm
thinking like the moore's murders and
stuff like that
when it's a man and a woman it's much
easier to like lure victims in because
it doesn't look as suspicious like i
said if it's just one
lone dude obviously everybody in the
world is gonna be like yeah that's
sketchy as [ __ ] but if it's a couple not
so much so i do kind of feel like they
exploit that to some degree and that's
absolutely what happens here um and
they're not pushy and i think that
that's something that kind of helps and
and like i said you can say oh you know
she was dumb for getting the car so like
that but the way it happens
seems realistic to me it's like i could
see that happening i don't know if i
would i don't think i would have done it
but
i can think of like a lot of people that
probably would have especially she's
kind of a little bit lost uh somebody's
coming to pick her up but they're kind
of you know way at the end of the
highway and it's you know middle of the
night so she's kind of walking down the
street and what is presumably like looks
like a very safe neighborhood had kids
playing outside and all this other kind
of stuff so she's kind of all tarted up
and she's walking down the street and
they just kind of like hey you know um
you do you want some weed that's what
they first asked they asked to sell her
some weed and at first she's like nah
it's okay and they're like you sure it's
really good and we got it right here and
stuff like that and she's like ah yeah
you know why not so she's initially just
gonna like buy drugs from them to take
to the party
and then they're just kind of like well
and then she's like oh i'm kind of lost
and so they kind of just and they don't
like i said they don't be like hey get
in the car they're like oh yeah you just
go that way and that way and that way
they like they give her directions and
then they're just kind of like um hey
you know we got some more and then like
they just kind of like weasel their way
into like getting her to come back to
the house to get the weed oh i thought i
had the weed in the car i don't have it
all this other kind of stuff she's very
reluctant but she does get in the car
eventually and like i said it might be
just because what it's a couple they
seem very nice they don't seem sketchy
there's a baby seat in the back you know
you're led to believe this is a family
how bad can it be
yeah it can be like really really bad
so once she gets back to the house they
kind of like talk her into
you know having a little bit of a drink
which they drug
and it's really kind of horrifying
because there's this this great like
chilling scene that's the use of music
in this is fantastic by the way so
there's one really chilling scene where
she's been drugged she hasn't like
gone completely unconscious yet but
she's just kind of like going in and out
of it
and the couple they put on um nights and
white satin that moody blues song
and
then they kind of start dancing
provocatively and like looking at her
and she realizes she's been drugged and
just like the look on her face just like
horrifying because she she realized oh
[ __ ] i'm like in big [ __ ] trouble now
but it's like that the use of that song
was just like so chilling and just like
so creepy it was just like the perfect
song for that moment because like i said
it's this
80s suburban like kind of low rent so
we're like everything's covered with
wood paneling and everything's kind of
grimy and it's just kind of like shitty
looking you know what i mean like
everything's kind of cheap looking so
and but then like this beautiful song
and it's just kind of like all sort of
hazy and distant and it was just like i
don't know it was like it kind of
freaked me out a little bit
so so yeah so she's still she tries to
escape but
they overpower her and uh basically
chain her to a bed
and uh proceed to do all kinds of
horrible things to her
while uh she
tries to
think of different ways to get out of
the situation
now interestingly in the real case of
david and catherine bernie and this like
i said this is very unusual this hardly
ever happens uh particularly in the
dynamic of couple serial killers
according to the surviving victim she
said that actually katherine bernie the
woman was actually the the worst like
the most uh aggressive and she was the
one that was like dominant uh at whereas
david was more submissive she was like
the boss
um i think that kind of happened a
little bit in fred and rosemary west
case too although i can't really
remember all the details of that but you
don't usually see that sometimes you see
the woman is like crueler
but sometimes that comes about because
they're trying to impress the man like
look how much more than [ __ ] up than
you i can be whereas in this situation
it did seem like catherine bernie the
real woman
uh was very much the boss
and in real life
uh the couple were the same age they'd
actually met as teenagers
and were both
equally [ __ ] up i suppose and
recognized that in one another and then
just went on their merry little way
in this movie this more explores
the more regular thing that happens in
serial killer couples whereby and like i
said i'm not excusing the female
character in this either because she did
some horrible [ __ ] also but evie in this
is portrayed as younger than john not
young young but she's
obviously like a little bit younger than
him
and it seems as though he
kind of groomed her also he is very very
um aggressive and violent uh it's also
implied very strongly that he has uh ocd
tendencies like she makes him breakfast
the same exact thing every day like you
know uh boiled egg and toast and she has
to arrange it just so like on the plate
like i said they don't it's unspoken but
little things like that like the way he
puts his shoes and the rack when he
comes in and he's very straightening you
know what i mean so uh the thing about
him is that
they seem to make their money
through selling drugs selling weed
and uh stealing [ __ ] out of their
neighbor's mailboxes which is a plot
point that comes into play later on with
their victim
so in the movie the dynamic is
it seems as though the the man john is
much much more
dominant
and he kind of keeps her and he keeps
the his wife in line because one she's
afraid that he will leave her
uh it's uh you know they they say that
she actually has a child or children
from a previous relationship but they
have been taken away from her i mean
obviously because she's got some issues
and so she's kind of like
hoping that she'll get them back
and she uh i guess she wanted him
because he was a little bit older he had
like money he had stability because she
says at one point to vicky you know he's
the reason that i have a you know money
you know food on the table and like a
roof over my head so she feels
it's almost like she like he's made her
a prisoner as well and it's interesting
because there's a dynamic too where
she seems to only go along with this
rape and murder thing of these teenage
girls
because that's what john wants because
even though we don't see the previous
victims we only see you know the the
thing play out with vicky
obviously um
evie is very
jealous because she says you know it
because i guess prior to this
it's implied that they had shared the
victims
whereas in this one it seems more like
john is
wanting
vicki like to do things to her like by
himself because he keeps like oh i'll
take her to the bathroom and like then
he locks the door which apparently he
never did before
and things like that so
some cracks start to appear in this
relationship because evie starts to
worry oh i'm getting too old you don't
want me anymore now you're just going
off and doing your thing with these
girls that we kidnap where previously we
were doing this together
and so he has that kind of like power
over her you know whereas she's just
kind of like like i said she's she's a
horrible person too but
she has a little bit more of a victim
thing going on because she's almost
become like
it's almost like a stockholm syndrome
thing or she's almost kind of like a
prisoner she's not a prisoner literally
like she can leave and [ __ ] like that
but she's kind of like an emotional
prisoner because she's afraid that he
will leave and he doesn't really give a
[ __ ] about her i mean like at one point
she like threatens she puts a knife to
her own throat and says you know all
then he's just like do it i don't give a
[ __ ] so he obviously doesn't give a [ __ ]
about her so he has like all this power
over her because she loves him and wants
to please him but he doesn't really give
a [ __ ] about her one way or the other
so you know again giving him power over
her now it's interesting because this
particular dynamic
when vicki is
you know trapped in their house you know
to chained to this bed that they have
her there
she notices this dynamic and she thinks
well this is a way that i can get out so
she starts appealing
to evie
and starts to kind of try to turn the
two of them against one another so that
she'll be able to escape and
ultimately that does actually end up
working in her favor this movie like i
said it's kind of um you know i don't
want to so much spoil the ending or
anything like that because this actually
does end
the movie ends differently than the real
life case the real life case ended with
uh you know one victim escaping uh which
is similar but
what happened after that was that you
know she the victim escaped and then
david and catherine bernie got caught
and arrested and convicted
david bernie hanged himself in prison
catherine bernie as far as i know is
still alive and still in prison she's
been up for parole several times but
never gets it and probably rightfully so
because like i said she seemed like she
was the the boss or the aggressor in
that uh couple dynamic
so she has not been let out she is still
in prison as far as i'm aware uh so the
movie plays out
quite a bit differently so like i said
it's very loosely based it's
i don't want to say it's really loosely
based because some of the details uh
particularly one of the things that
vicky does where she does this like
coded letter thing and tries to tell you
know she's because they make her send a
letter to her family saying oh i moved
away like to adelaide or whatever so
they don't like come looking for her
like i ran away
and her like coding the letter i think
them making her write letters that was
that really happened and them trying to
like the couple trying to
uh make the victim take a bunch of pills
and like kill herself that happened as
well so that part is true but it ended
in a this movie ends in like a way
different way like in a more
i don't know if it's like a more
cinematic way i guess i don't know if i
want to that's exactly the word i want
to use but it doesn't end exactly the
way that it did in real life
uh and again going back to what i was
saying earlier about like the brilliant
use of music the final scene
because
uh you know vicki has written this coded
letter so but something happens where
the the message that she put in there is
not
correct
so uh her family are kind of like
looking for her her mom and her dad and
her boyfriend
and so there's this whole thing so this
this final scene is just so
nail-biting you're just like on the edge
of you oh my god is she going to get
away is she going to get killed is it
and it's just like man i was just really
like on the edge of my seat the whole
time and i was just like my stomach was
in a knot like that like oh my god it
was like really really intense
and then like the last shot they
actually started playing um atmosphere
by joy division and i just thought that
was a really really good musical choice
you want to hear something weird i saw
this other i can't remember what channel
it was but i was just watching like a
whole bunch of different like reviews of
this just to see like what other people
thought about it and this one guy
didn't like the last shot he's like
because it seemed to go on forever
because it was like slow motion which
there is a lot of slow motion in this
but
it's not slow motion just for the sake
of slow motion it's you know it's kind
of uh you know tying in with the theme
and stuff it is thematically relevant so
this pat the last scene does kind of go
on for a while but he didn't like that
and he's like and he thought the music
choice was spooky he didn't know that
song which i thought was kind of funny
and then he also thought um he said
something like am i at a hipster
wedding or a hipster and i'm like is joy
division's hipster now like since when
did that happen i was like that song
came out of like 1979 and like suddenly
everyone's like [ __ ] for being histor
and i was just kind of like okay i guess
i'm old you know i remember that song
came out and i was just kind of like i
thought it was funny that one he didn't
know who that was because that seemed a
little uh culturally dumb but you know
because i kind of feel like most people
would probably know what that song was
or at least would recognize what era it
came from uh but the fact that he
thought that it was like some hipster
thing i was just like okay i must be
getting old i don't know how old that
guy was but i just thought that was like
really funny but anyway
uh but that whole final scene with that
song playing i mean that's easily one of
my favorite songs of all time anyway and
it always uh i don't know it's just like
a really emotionally resonant song for
me and
i mean the the use of it in this movie
kind of rivals the use of it in
24-hour party people where they actually
used it in a more on-the-nose fashion
where they it was ian curtis's funeral
uh you know ian curtis from joy division
who wrote that song you know when he
died and they played that song at his
funeral in that movie
but in this one you know it doesn't have
anything to do with that but
it's just it was still like really
emotionally powerful like the way that
they used it so it does kind of like
make you choke up at the end but like i
said the the tension of it is like
really [ __ ] up i mean this is one of
the most
disturbing
and like i said they don't show a lot a
lot of it is implied like
like before like when they first bring
in vicky
there's still like some stuff from the
previous victim who they've killed
and you don't really see her you only
see her from like far away
and there's just this shot of like the
floor and like evie and they're like
cleaning up like from their last victim
because i guess maybe they do this every
weekend or every i don't know it's just
like [ __ ] up
so they just kidnap somebody and have
fun with them for a few days and then
they kill them and dump them someplace
so so she's cleaning up from the last
victim and all that you see like on the
floor
is just all these balled up like piece
of toilet paper with like blood on them
and then like this big huge like wooden
dildo and you're just so you can so it's
like that so it's just like you can
imagine and in a way that kind of makes
it [ __ ] worse because you're just
like imagining what's going on and the
one kind of rape scene that's in there
with john and vicki like i said it
doesn't show a lot but it implies so
much that you're just kind of like
it's just oh it was horrifying to watch
i'm just i'm really really bothered by
rape scenes in movies anyway uh i do
watch movies with them in there but it's
always
one of those things that's just kind of
like ah it just always makes me feel
like really really gross but this one i
think the fact that they showed less
which is kind of like so i will say you
know if you're not super into like
watching it's not really graphic or
anything but
there's enough of it implied that you're
just going to feel really really
nasty and gross afterwards because
you'll be just like oh [ __ ] that but
yeah it's just kind of like that um also
i will note that if you are
sensitive to cruelty to animals which i
am as well a dog does get killed in this
like i said it's not graphic
but
uh you know it's in there and it kind of
bothered me as it always does so as i
said this is a kind of a brutal movie
not in the sense of them showing
everything it's not gory or anything
like that but just
the stuff that they leave to your
imagination there's enough of an
implication there that it really is very
very disturbing and very very unpleasant
to watch but again that said
the acting in this is incredible the guy
that plays john i had never seen him in
anything else but apparently his name's
stephen curry i think he is apparently
in australia is quite well known as a
comedic actor comedic actor and so the
fact that he was in this and was [ __ ]
creepy as [ __ ] man fair play that was
like some [ __ ]
damn okay so yeah i said i don't know
i've never seen him in anything else but
apparently he's usually a comedian so
seeing him in this i'm sure was like
really uh
probably really upsetting for some
people but everybody in this is good all
three of the uh principles are great um
and like i said very very brave very raw
performances but yeah uh as i said if
you're not real into
very realistic depictions of rape and
you know serial killers and just
everything being scuzzy and
that kind of stuff like i said henry
portrait of serial killer snowtown stuff
like that if you don't want to watch
that i get it but this is actually quite
a great movie
uh if you're in the right uh headspace
if you're in the right mindset for it
and i would definitely recommend it if
it if it sounds like something that
you'd be willing to sit through uh then
yeah i thought it was uh actually quite
awesome so that will do it for this
episode of flickr's fear and i will see
you guys on the next one bye